متظاهرون غاضبون اعمده نيران ونهب للمتاجر
وغاز مسيل للدموع لتفريق المتظاهرين هي
اولى ردود فعل الشارع الفرنسي على قانون
التقاعد الذي اعتمدته الحكومه بمقتضى احدى
مواد الدستور وليس عبر التصويت في مجلس
الويب مشهد كاشف لحاله الانقسام التي
انتهت اليها فرنسا بسبب تعديل اثار ولا
يزال لغطا وجدلا في الاوساط السياسيه كما
عند عامه الناس
وبينما كان مجلس النواب في حاله غليان كان
فرنسيون يتابعون تفاصيل المشهد خارج اسوار
المجلس
هو المخرج
السعيد لكن اظن انها مناوره ولا خيار لنا
الا ان نواصل النضال لكي لا يطبق القانون
ابدا
لجوء الحكومه الى عدم التصويت على مشروعها
لم يرق المعارضه
[موسيقى]
اهانه للبرلمان وهذا يظهر المعنى الذي
يعطيه الرئيس للديمقراطي وحتى ان جرى
التصويت بشكل عادي كنت ساعتبر ان الحكومه
تواصل اهانه اربعين مليون عامل فرنسي لقد
اصبح واضحا ان هذا الاصلاح يعارضه ملايين
العمال
النقابات لم يتاخر ردها الغاضب على خطوه
الحكومه فدعت الى تصعيد التعبئه ومواصله
الاضرابات سنواصل معارضه هذا القانون
وسنحاول بكل الوسائل لمحاربته هناك عده
خيارات بينها اللجوء الى المجلس الدستوري
او تنظيم استفتاء سنقرر الخطوات خلال
اجتماعات تنسيقيه النقابات لكن لن نترك
القانون يمر ولن نستسلم وهذا شيء مؤكد
ما حدث في مجلس النواب اغضب المعارضه
بمختلف اطيافها واستفز الشارع فقد تجمع
مئات الاشخاص في ساحه الوئام بباريس على
بعض اللافتات كتب من يزرع البؤس يجني
الغضب
مشروع القانون الذي رفضته النقابات جماعيا
ويحتج عليه الشارع منذ عده اسابيع سيعتبر
مصدقا عليه الا اذا سحبت الثقه من الحكومه
اظن ان الحكومه هشه وانه سيجري تعديل
وزاري على الاقل مع حل مجلس النواب كخطوه
ناجمه عن عريضه سحب الثقه التي تقدم بها
حزب يساري مستقل واتوقع ان يصوت عليها
اليمين واليسار اللذان يعارضان هذا
القانون
لم تكتب بعده على ما يبدو نهايه السيناريو
الذي سيحسم النزاع بشان مشروع اصلاح نظام
التقاعد كما لا يعرف بعد كيف ستترجم على
الارض المخاطر السياسيه التي جازف بها
الرئيس ماكرون بتمسكه باصلاح لا يحظى
بالاجماع في بلد صار منقسما على نفسه نور
الدين بوزيان الجزيره باريس